governor desantis the man on the side of
safety
and freedom for his citizens joins us
now governor
uh thank you for being with us tonight
now after you made your announcement
i know you probably missed this you were
a little busy but
cnn's dr sanjay gupta had this to say
the idea of reopening when we're nowhere
near containment there's just
way too much viral transmission governor
desantis has gone through this before
you saw what happened when they had that
big spike that's when they reopened
that's obviously a concern but inside
restaurants
with full capacity there's no mass
mandate there's no fine
these are all the wrong sort of
decisions as far as actually trying to
bring this pandemic under control
governor you're gonna get a lot of this
but they're waving the caution flag the
danger flag the warning flag tonight
about your decision
why are you right and why are they wrong
well i think a lot of them are ignorant
about florida i mean we never closed
down over the summer he was talking
about the sun belt spike
we actually had of course beaches theme
parks
retail operating at 100 percent we had
sports and summer camps over the summer
we have over 1.1 million students in
face-to-face instruction for k-12
we have college students that are on
campus we've had big events such as
nfl with fans college football with fans
we had a nascar race with 30
000 people so we've been open the final
kind of piece to the puzzle was this uh
capacity limitation on the restaurants
at 50
and so that was uh the announcement
today kind of
brought that in for a landing and a lot
of those folks in that industry
have had a really really rough time
they've learned a lot about how to
create a safe environment and i think
that they'll be able to do that going
forward
so i think it'll end up being good for
for jobs i think it'll end up being good
for their business
and i also think laura we have to have a
situation where
individuals can make decisions about
what makes sense for them
and uh and if that's something you're
not comfortable doing no one's gonna
force you to do it
uh but i do think that people need to be
free to choose
now governor this is something that joe
biden said this week on the trail
about quote national standards
president has to take control has to
take responsibility
set national standards making sure we're
in a position where
the president lays out standards for
opening schools opening businesses
well that ends up being code for
national mask
mandates and rolling lockdowns which
frankly americans i think are just sick
and tired of they're beyond this
and in fact governor a guest we had on
last night was arrested
earlier this week for not wearing a mask
outside watch
i should not be doing this and doing
this kind of crap for the mayor this is
embarrassing
taste somebody governor this
these look like scenes out of russia a
man singing a hymn
with others a woman sitting at a sports
event
what's going on here what is this really
all about
well i'll tell you laura in florida we
never we did any of that but in other
states you would see churches be
banned but you could go to a casino uh
basic rights
uh deprived and it was oftentimes on a
political basis
uh i am worried though about this i mean
joe biden has said he will lock down the
country
if a scientist tells him to do it i had
a great round table it's on my
twitter and facebook with three very
eminent scientists yesterday talking
about all these issues
dr martin caldor from harvard medical
and jay bhattacharya
and michael levitt from stanford medical
and i asked should lockdowns be off the
table
and they all said unequivocally yes
lockdown should be off the table
at best what they do is just delay
infections they do not reduce mortality
but they cause catastrophic damage and
so
that should be off the table in this
country going forward we need our
society to function
because you know covet 19 is one health
issue there's a whole
host of other health issues out there
that get exacerbated
when you have society on its knees i
want to talk about the state of florida
and the presidential
race a governor desantis given how close
it was
last time around the president has
expressed his extreme
concern with mail-in voting not absentee
voting which is very popular in your
state but with
mail-in voting how do you think things
stand now
in your state given where the polls are
and given where you think the people are
after this very difficult year
well just be clear we don't have mass
mail voting in florida what we have as
you mentioned is
mail voting on requests absentee voting
so voters can request it
they will get sent a ballot and then
they can send it in it's tried true and
safe so if people want to vote that way
they should absolutely do it but we are
not indiscriminately sending out ballots
all over the state of florida that that
doesn't work
and you also have to have sent in the
ballot by election day
at 7 p.m there's not going to be a
situation where ballots are just showing
up
a week after the election i think that
that's very chaotic look i think he's in
good shape it's always tough
here it's never an easy race but if you
look in 2016 he did
really poorly in miami-dade county still
won the state
he's doing a lot better in miami-dade
he's got really strong support
from hispanics i think he'll win
hispanics in miami-dade county
and if he holds the support elsewhere
you know i think he's definitely
that i think he's definitely going to be
in good shape biden has really not done
much in florida
uh you know we have a ground game we're
registering voters going door to door
their campaign hasn't wanted to do that
because of the pandemic
when trump won in 2016 we had a 340 000
vote deficit with democrats for
registration
we've now shrunk that to under 190 000
that's as close as we've ever been
probably in modern history in terms of
registration i think that bodes well for
us
are you worried about michael
bloomberg's efforts to
pay the penalties the fines of
former felons who would then get the
right to vote if their fines were paid
six well our attorney general is
investigating that um
it's a situation where he's doing it
he's discriminating on the basis of race
he's only paying off if you're a certain
race
and basically i think someone in his
organization said yeah because we think
they'll vote
for the candidate we want and under
florida law that very well may run afoul
of that
so we'll have to see but it is being
investigated and it may be investigated
federally but it certainly is
investigated by the state attorney
general
in the state of florida and governor
just one more time i'm going to ask one
more question
will you ever consider locking down
your state large parts of your state as
the governor of new york
i guess they're now considering it in
new york city today we learn
because of some outbreaks you will never
do that in your state
zero zero percent chance of that okay
governor thank you so much great to see
you tonight